the world's and blizzards universes
collide without logic in the developers
upcoming multiplayer online battle arena
game heroes of the storm the game
features a cast of characters from the
Warcraft Starcraft and Diablo franchises
and although Blizzard has teased several
possible additions a number of figures
still remain in the shadows so I've put
together a list of some favorites so I
think would fit well into the game
Medivh was a powerful human mage who
started the events of 1994's Warcraft
orcs and humans by opening a portal and
bringing the orcish race to Azeroth he
was killed for his acts but returned in
Warcraft 3 rain of chaos to repent for
his sins
Medivh has consorted with demons giving
him access to dark magic that would be
useful on the battlefield and heroes of
the storm the demon king of pit Lords
Mannoroth clashed with players in
Warcraft 3 rain of chaos and showcased
his ability to summon demonic minions
and cast Earthquake face spells while
equipped with a large two bladed sword
armed with fiery talents and the ability
to summon minions Mannoroth has the
potential to wreak chaos and battles
with a disruptive and lethal skillset in
the Warcraft universe
murlocs our race of humanoids with
reptilian features Merle can be
interpreted as the sound milk's make
when attacking and is also the name of
this melech chieftain armed with the
spear Merle could cast shaman spells
that would make him a strong damage
dealer in heroes of the storm with his
vibrant appearance and unique vocal
cries this Merle of cheatin would
certainly brighten up the battlefield
the hybrid was the result of experiments
which combined Zerg and Protoss DNA
producing units that had both psionic
abilities and strong physical form with
Protoss exclusive skills and strong
physical defense may be potentially
suitable as a carrion heroes of the
storm dishing out damage and soaking
attacks with their zone carapace armor
vice-admiral Alexei Zhukov has
demonstrated up to combat and leadership
skills throughout the Starcraft series
experiencing Zerg infestation twice he
showed he was capable of throwing out
skills enhanced by his infestation while
retaining human level intelligence the
regeneration abilities granted by his
Zerg DNA could help to sustain health
during battles giving him more
survivability in heroes of the storm one
of the lesser evils in the Diablo series
Belial is known less formidable as the
Lord of Lies he was capable of taking on
different forms to deceive add an
affinity for fiery eruptions and he
would bring a scary amount of damaging
skills into the fray the Archangel of
Hope Oriole is one of the angels who
voted in favor of saving humanity her
vote paid off as she was rescued by
players in Diablo 3 Oriol uses a whip
like weapon and oh my ash the court of
hope it burns opponents and binds
enemies immobilizing them Oriol also
uses it to heal allies and grants mental
clarity showing she can heal as much as
destroy which could be used to support
allies in heroes of the storm errors of
the storm brings with it the chance to
draw upon a wealth of lore and bring old
characters into a new age but the game
currently in technical alpha there still
remains an opportunity for old favorites
to make a return